[موسيقى]
اتهمه الرئيس الروسي من وصفهم بمنافسي
روسيا الاستراتيجيين بان لهم هدفا تاريخيا
هو اضعاف روسيا وتفتيتها واضاف بروتين
خلال اجتماع نهايه العامه قاده وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه ان حلف الناتو يستخدمه
قدراته كامله ضد روسيا وهي تعلم بكل
المعطيات بهذا الشان وتعهد الرئيس الروسي
بان تحقق بلاده جميع اهدافها العسكريه في
اوكرانيا والمحافظه على توازن الردع
النووي الذي وصفه بانه اساس الاستقرار في
العالم كما اكد بوتين مواصله دعم القدرات
النوويه الروسيه وزياده القوه
الاستراتيجيه بجميع الاسلحه الحديثه مثل
صواريخ سارمات وتسيركن التي قال انه لا
مثيل لها في العالم ودع بوتين القاده
العسكريين الى استخدام خبراتهم المكتسبه
من